[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID KEEGAN: So if I could
start by taking you back
to 2009, Ireland
was experiencing
what the media called
a suicide epidemic,
and it didn't really
feature highly
on anyone's list of priorities.
And I could never
quite understand
why you couldn't change the
TV channel for seeing a road
safety ad, but at
the time there were
more people dying by suicide
than there were on the roads.
But you never saw an
ad for mental health.
It didn't really feature in
civil discourse at the time,
and it wasn't a conversation
that was being had.
And there's a lot
of reasons for that.
One, it's not an easy
conversation to have.
So I shared a house with a
pal of mine, JP, who we've
known since our late teens.
And he came to me
one day and said,
would you like to help me
run a mental health event?
And my reaction was, a what?
And, you see, he didn't--
I knew his older brother
David had died by suicide when
he was 16, but we'd never
really spoken about it
because it's not an easy
conversation to have.
So what he didn't
know at the time
was that I'd been
self-harming from the same age
and did enough to scratch
too far under the surface
to discover depression,
schizophrenia,
and suicide leafed
throughout my family tree.
One in four of us will suffer
with a mental health problem
at some point in our life.
We carry out annual
research around attitudes
to mental health in the country,
and our research actually
indicates that it's
actually far worse.
47% of the people we
interviewed had openly admitted
to having a mental
health problem
at some point in their
life, with 4 in 10 people
also admitting to
delaying seeking help
for fear of stigmatization.
So back to, I suppose,
my own story again.
He didn't know that
I was kind of going
through this at the time.
And, again, it was nothing--
we didn't talk about any
of this stuff with my family.
Again, it's not an
easy conversation
to have at a kitchen table.
So when we sat
down, the intention
was to design a
model or a catalyst
to start a national mental
health conversation,
and we'd shared interest
in arts and culture.
It's my background.
JP worked in mental health
services at the time.
He's a psychotherapist
and a social worker.
And our perspective was
that culture reflects
who we are societally, and
artists have always championed
issues of great
social importance,
whether it be hunger,
AIDS, or equality,
and great art can
effect great change.
So my name is,
again, David Keegan.
I'm CEO of First Fortnight.
First Fortnight,
Ireland's National Mental
Health Arts Festival.
And every year, we start
kitchen table conversations.
We challenge stigma, race,
awareness, true cultural action
in the form of mental
health arts festival.
The challenging time of year
for a lot of people in January.
And in 2013, we became a
mental health service provider,
delivering free mental health
care to vulnerable communities
across Dublin.
Predominantly people in
homeless communities or people
at risk of experiencing
homelessness.
And, I suppose, it's with
great pride that this year,
particularly, this
January, we will
host Europe's mental
health festival
in communities across Ireland.
And I'd invite you all to
join us and end mental health
stigma together.
That's me in a
nutshell right now.
Thanks.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
Thanks, David.
DAVID KEEGAN: Yeah.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
So I'm going
to kick off a few
questions, and then we'll
go to audience Q&A. Marina
has a microphone ready
to hand around to you guys.
So thank you for being
here, and thank you for--
DAVID KEEGAN: Just turn
around and look at you.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: And thank
you for this amazing festival.
DAVID KEEGAN: Thanks.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
It's really important,
and I think it's an amazing
thing for a group of people
to come together and build
up over the past 10 years.
So when you and JP discussed
this idea maybe 11 years ago,
or would it be 12 years ago--
DAVID KEEGAN: It started-- he
had his bright idea in 2009.
Yeah.
That's where the
conversation started.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
And in 2009,
did either of you, even
in your wildest dreams,
imagine that it would develop
into something so important
and so successful, so loved?
DAVID KEEGAN: No, we didn't
have any idea whatsoever.
We just knew that we had
a degree of influence
amongst our peers, and we
had an amount of experience
in the relevant
areas, and we cared.
And we were directly seeing
the effects of stigma
all around us.
I mean, it's probably not--
I would imagine there's
probably not many people--
all of us would probably
know or be one person removed
from someone who has had
a mental health difficulty
or died by suicide within
our kind of peer group.
So we were seeing
this all around us
and had direct
personal experience.
Change doesn't come from
above, it comes from people.
And so that was literally it.
We just kind of
combined our powers.
And we approached our
friends who were in bands
or worked in kind of
the cultural sector,
and we approached other friends
who worked in the media.
And they played
at this one event
in a place called Andrew's
Lane Theatre, which
no longer exists.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: Yeah.
Unfortunately.
DAVID KEEGAN: And we partnered
with Mental Health Ireland.
Our friends played as part
of the event and the media
wrote about it.
And we filled our venue.
We sold it out.
And it exceeded all
of our expectations.
We were completely humbled
by the outpouring of support
we got.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
When did you
know so that it wasn't
going to be a once off?
That you guys had
to keep doing this?
DAVID KEEGAN: We were approached
very soon after the first one
to see if we were
interested to do it again.
Yeah.
It was directly afterwards.
After the first
one, we kind of--
we felt we'd hit a--
it was the zeitgeist moment.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: Yeah.
DAVID KEEGAN: We
just felt people
wanted it, were ready
for that conversation,
and it was needed.
It needed that this public
discourse needed to happen,
and it was a thing that we
just weren't talking about.
And so that was it.
Mental Health Ireland
came back to us and said,
will you do it again?
And that's where
it started, really.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
That's amazing.
DAVID KEEGAN: Yeah.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: And
in 10 years from now,
where do you think this
conversation will be?
The conversation either
on mental health,
or on First Fortnight,
or similar festivals.
DAVID KEEGAN: The conversation
is different year to year.
So we try to explore--
I mean, we started
off at one event,
and it was a music event.
So, I suppose, our
programming policy
is to program high quality art.
It's high quality art that has
the potential to effect change.
And, again, it's people
will relate to it.
With that one event,
we're constantly
looking for how we
could have more impact.
That was one genre of what
could potentially be a festival,
an arts festival,
and each genre of art
has its own unique
medium for communication.
So in a lot of
ways, the festival
itself is just a
medium to communicate
a positive mental health
message or explore mental health
themes, and then
contextualize everything
with conversation and debate.
So that was kind of--
I suppose you tested the
model in Andrew's Lane.
It's where social
enterprise-- it's very--
that's kind of how we've
always approached it.
The festival itself
generates an income,
and the income is
reinvested into the service
to manage and
maintain its growth,
and then also invest it
into the free services
that we provide to
homeless communities.
So we tested that model in
2010 with our very first event,
and then 2011 we
needed a bigger venue.
We had a new partner in
Amnesty International
because they had a
campaign around--
their focus was mental
health as a human right.
And so we kind of developed
the program a bit more.
We decided to do a mental
health talk at 2 o'clock
in the afternoon in
the Button Factory.
It was a bigger venue
with a bigger capacity.
It was 750 was the capacity.
And, again, we had a mental
health talk at half two,
and then a gig
later on that day.
So we put out about 150
seats in the Button Factory
to have this mental health talk.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: Was
this the middle of the day?
DAVID KEEGAN: This is it.
And you're kind of,
like, in the situation
where it's like you're throwing
a party and you're like,
who's going to come?
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
Who's going to come?
DAVID KEEGAN: Yeah.
It's totally that situation.
And we only put out
150 seats, and then
people started to come
in, and they kept coming,
and they kept coming,
and we ended up
having to put out
another 100 seats.
And the venue is packed.
And we're like, this
is something here.
Like--
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID KEEGAN: Like, yeah.
So we were floored.
And then we had an event
on later that night.
And, again, we
sold it out again.
And then that was in
partnership, as I said,
with Amnesty.
And then year three--
so we've basically done this--
just to say, this
is purely voluntary.
So both myself and JP
had full-time jobs.
He worked in HSC at
the time, I worked
at Pavilion Theatre
in Dun Laoghaire
as a kind of Marketing
Communications Manager.
So it was completely
in our spare time,
and asking our friends to do
bits and pieces to help us out.
So we did it.
And then into year three, we
kind of felt confident enough
then.
We tested the model
two years in a row.
There was an appetite.
There was an audience.
People were buying
tickets, and we
were raising a significant
amount of money,
and we were basically
donating this
to our mental health partners.
In year one, it was
Mental Health Ireland.
We donated to them.
And then Amnesty afterwards.
But year three when
we decided, all right,
we can do a full
blown festival now,
and try to program a
broad amount of kind of--
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
Spectrum of theater styles.
DAVID KEEGAN: Genres.
We included theater, film,
spoken word poetry, music.
But we just made kind
of a mature decision
that we needed to kind
of register as a company,
subsequently register
as a charity to reinvest
in ourselves.
Because we were
giving the money away,
we had no money
the following year
to reinvest in the
festival program.
We couldn't book venues,
we couldn't necessarily
program because we
didn't know what money we
were going to have.
But we were very good
at finding the money.
We were better at, like,
deciding whether or not
what we were going to do
was going to have an impact.
If we agreed it was
going to have an impact,
then we found the money
to do it after the fact.
Because we weren't paying
anybody at the time.
It was voluntary.
And that's kind of how
it started to develop
from the first festival.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: Yeah.
That's amazing.
So I missed the first few years
of the festival, unfortunately.
I was living abroad.
When I came back, one of
the first pieces I saw
was "HALF LIGHT."
DAVID KEEGAN: Oh, yeah.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
Which was beautiful.
It's a beautiful show.
From what I remember, it's
a little boy's exploration
into where his father
is, and his father
is suffering from depression.
So he's trying to find his dad
again and reconnect with them.
And it's beautiful, but it's
so wise and intelligent.
I love that piece.
It really stuck with me.
What have been
some of the ones--
some of your highlights
over the years?
Is that an awful
question to ask you?
Sorry.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DAVID KEEGAN: What are
your favorite children?
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: Who
are your favorite children?
DAVID KEEGAN: I
loved "HALF LIGHT."
I just loved the message in it.
It was appropriate for kids,
and families, and adults.
And it's like, is this kid's
kind of little fantasy--
he builds his own little fantasy
land of exactly that-- trying
to find the dad he's more
familiar than the dad who's
suffering with depression, but
he doesn't know what it is.
It's not named.
It's just a thing.
It's just not the dad he knows.
And so he's on this
little journey and--
yeah.
I loved it.
But, like, what I heard
anecdotally after the fact,
I'd been told about a person who
was involved with the festival,
and they had come
along with their kids
to one of the performances.
And he had confided in me
that they'd brought along--
and he'd actually suffered at
that one stage with depression,
but they'd never really
talked about it as a family.
And so essentially--
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
It's lovely.
Is there a way--
DAVID KEEGAN:
Well, this is the--
well, not actually,
because he was
in a better place
at the time when
he brought-- when
the kids came along
and they went as a family.
And after the fact, he
got in touch to say,
actually, we came out of
the show and one of the kids
actually turned
around and said, dad,
is that what you were going
through, or kind of a thing?
And then that opened up
the opportunity for him
to have that conversation
with his kid.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
That's amazing.
DAVID KEEGAN: And then kind of
gain a level of understanding
about what had happened.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: What
an insightful little child.
DAVID KEEGAN: Absolutely.
Yeah.
And so we're very
familiar that what we do
does have an impact because
there's lots of research
around creativity
and mental health,
and it having a good,
positive social impact.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: I'm
hearing no favorites, David.
DAVID KEEGAN: So, yeah.
I loved that.
What else?
Like, there's been so many
pieces that have come through.
What have been my favorites?
I should have really
thought about this
before I kind of
sat down with you.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
Oh, that's OK.
We can come back
to that later on.
We've probably had a few
people in the audience who've
been to a few and might be
able to share some of theirs.
DAVID KEEGAN: Like some of our--
one of the things that we do
is we partner with the Fringe
Festival--
Dublin Fringe Festival.
And every year, they have
the Fringe Festival awards
like the Spirit of the
Fringe, or Best Production.
We partnered with them
because we wanted to award
a piece of theater that
speaks to the mission of First
Fortnight's challenge
in mental health stigmas
or experimental health themes.
And the very first year
we offered that award,
there were, I think, four pieces
shortlisted for consideration
for our award, and a piece won.
It was called "Dolls."
And the point of "Dolls"
was it was like a--
it bombarded all of your senses.
It was kind of like
movement in a dance piece,
but essentially was kind
of mixed multimedia.
It was, like, really bright
light and really loud
piece with movement,
and it was repetitive.
And then it showed very
kind of graphic images,
but they were graphic images
that we see on a daily basis.
But, ultimately, the
point of the piece
was to present what
women have to go through
and what they have to kind
of experience in the media.
What they're told.
The messaging that's
consistently--
is on rotation,
basically, and the impact
that it has to women
and their mental health.
And then we kind of
contextualized the whole thing
with post-show debate
about new ways of--
or challenging media,
and stuff like that.
So the ones that have
kind of come through--
so that was-- when we offered
that award, as I said,
there were four
pieces shortlisted.
So we did that award this year.
And I think there's 24 pieces
shortlisted by the Fringe
Festival, with another 6.
So our intention by
offering that award
was that we only have so much
time to see art to program.
And so to the
Fringe Festival, we
get to see now
all of their work,
but not only just see the
work and then award it.
It's actually encourage--
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
It's another platform.
DAVID KEEGAN: --and
encourage more work.
Inspire more work to
be made in this vein
and challenge societal
norms that really should
be challenged at this stage.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
And can you tell us yet
who you've chosen for
next year from the--
DAVID KEEGAN: Fringe Festival?
Yeah.
It's called "Infinity."
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
Who's presenting that?
Do you know off the
top of your head?
Sorry to put you on the spot.
DAVID KEEGAN: God, someone
look-- open the program there,
and they'll be able to tell me.
But it's a beautiful piece
of theater around, I suppose,
again, the bombardment on
our senses and, you know,
the digital kind of impact
of communication nowadays.
And, I suppose, the
anxiety around just how
bombarded we are by--
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
The constant flashing
or the light on your phone?
DAVID KEEGAN: Exactly.
Yeah.
And it's kind of--
the message is that it's
kind of OK to not be OK.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: Yeah.
DAVID KEEGAN: But, yeah,
it was a fantastic piece,
and an easy one for us
to judge on this year.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: Brilliant.
Over the years, have you noticed
in what way, or if at all,
the conversations during
the festival have changed?
Like maybe the Q&A afterwards.
Have they changed at all?
How is the conversation
developing?
DAVID KEEGAN: I think--
best example I can give you
is we worked with a band
when we were kind
of starting off.
I think it was into
our first four years.
And we worked with a band, and
they were quite a high profile
band at the time.
So we had kind of extended
an invitation to participate.
We always provide
the opportunity
for artists who want to
speak on the subject of--
or the themes raised in the
festival program, the themes
that we want to
discuss by programming
the festival the way we do.
You don't have to have had
a mental health problem.
This festival is for everybody.
It's actually just exploring
mental health themes.
There's a lot in
there for everyone
to kind of get
their head around.
But, essentially, after the
festival had happened and--
so I asked it at this
particular event that happened.
It was a music event.
One of the members of that
band kind of approached
myself and my co-founder and
was really apologetic and very,
very emotional because
they didn't necessarily
know what they were
participating in.
It was more an opportunity
to play this big gig that
was happening.
But, actually, it
was over the course
of their involvement in the
festival that they'd come to--
they'd apparently gone
to their record company,
because they'd recently had a
diagnosis of manic depression,
and they approached their
publisher to find out whether
or not they could share
that story through the media
because they were doing
an article for a national
broadsheet, and the advice
was given that they shouldn't.
So then they performed
the event and realized
retrospectively, you know,
the impact that we were trying
to have and the reasons
that we were programming
these types of events
and the festival itself,
and he was hugely emotional,
massively apologetic--
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: Of course,
there are emotional moments.
DAVID KEEGAN: --for not having
shared his story because that
was kind of the point.
But, look, the
other side of it is
that he may not have been
ready to share that story.
Because we bring
a lot of attention
to the program itself, and it's
a very personal kind of journey
someone has to take to
be comfortable enough
to share that story
and shine a light on it
because the stigma is still so
prevalent in today's society,
which is--
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
And how is the Q&A,
the after show conversations?
Have they changed?
Are people asking new
questions, or are more people
asking questions?
DAVID KEEGAN: Sorry.
I kind of ducked that
question a little bit
by giving an anecdote.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: Sorry.
DAVID KEEGAN: So has
the conversation--
I'll tell you, the
conversations have changed.
I think people are
a lot more open
to talking about mental health.
In my experience, it tends
to be one person removed
from the person
you're talking about.
Now, I've been in a
very privileged position
in that I've been doing this
a long time and my friends
feel very comfortable
to talk to me about what
they might be going through,
or a family situation,
or whatever.
But if it's someone
that I tend not to know,
it tends to be one person
removed from the person--
someone else's problem.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
[INAUDIBLE] distance.
DAVID KEEGAN: And there's also--
there still seems
to be a distance.
And there's, like--
I mean, now you can go on
any social media channel
and you'll generally
see something every day
about mental health in the feed.
But, again, social media
now has just become,
you know-- you're numb to it.
You see it in a feed, but how
much do you-- see the headline,
but do you actually
read the story?
How much of an impact
does it actually have?
So yeah, it's a
lot more prevalent,
but stigma and culture
takes a long time to change.
And it presents another
problem, not really a problem,
but I think the
conversation's so prevalent,
and it's, again, I'd
like to think we're
part of that cultural shift.
But now people are happy to
talk about mental health more
openly or even address
issues before they
become serious problems.
But if you rely on
public services,
the help really isn't there.
You're going on a waiting
list for six to nine months.
And if you're in a
state of emergency,
that's where you're going.
You're going to
the emergency room,
and you'll be given a priority.
And that's something that
really needs to change.
So in terms of the
dialogue as well, I mean,
two years ago we started a
campaign in collaboration
with one of our mental health
partners, Mental Health Reform.
And it was around 24 hours, 7
day a week emergency service
provision.
The following year,
Minister Jim Daly
announced that it
would be happening,
but it would be set up 24-hour
care, five days a week.
So you can see it shifting.
Now, it's slow to shift, but
they're all positive changes,
certainly going the
right direction.
But like instead of
answering questions around,
I did a talk for--
I'm not sure if you're familiar
with the Federation of Music
Collectives, or Hard
Working Class Heroes.
It's a festival,
like music festival
that goes on in the city.
So I was asked to
participate in a talk
about music and mental health.
And one of the questions
I was asked about
was about the
pressures on musicians
to merely create a
mental illness in order
to bring focus onto your
music or the pressures
they feel to open
up about things
that they wouldn't necessarily
be comfortable with to bring
attention or promote the
music that they're trying to--
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: As it's
their social responsibility?
Was that what the--
DAVID KEEGAN: No, not even.
Almost like saying
like it's disingenuous.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
If they don't?
DAVID KEEGAN: Yeah, that it's
not necessarily a problem.
That it wasn't
necessarily depression,
but that they're calling
it depression in order
to bring attention
to their music.
And I don't know whether
or not I buy into that.
But it seemed to--
I saw a lot of nods
when the questions
were asked in the room, so it
seemed to be a shared opinion.
So that's quite toxic.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
That's very toxic.
DAVID KEEGAN: And I don't know
really where that comes from.
And I wonder, is it part
of like that we're just
like numb to how prevalent we
see it in social media field
feeds?
But how many meaningful
conversations
do you realistically
have about mental health?
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
Do you think--
is it another way of
promoting the stigma,
or protecting yourself from
being involved in the stigma,
having that attitude,
do you think?
DAVID KEEGAN: Having
the attitude as to be--
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
That those artists are--
she is really depressed,
he's not really depressed.
They're doing it
because it helps--
they're saying this because
it helps sell their album.
Is it another way of just
ignoring the problem,
or is it fear?
DAVID KEEGAN: I
think it comes back
to this idea of presenting your
best self on social media, that
people then [INAUDIBLE]
Irish speak,
like even though it's
like we're on Google
and it's multicultural.
But I don't know if you've
ever heard of Irish begrudgery?
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: You should
explain Irish begrudgery.
We might be the only
two Irish people.
Well, there's maybe four of us.
DAVID KEEGAN: OK,
Irish begrudgery
is, we're happy
for you to do OK,
but if you do better than OK--
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
Get back down.
DAVID KEEGAN: Yeah, you
need to find your place
and you need to be on a
level with everybody else.
No one wants to see
someone else be successful.
That tends to be the--
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: But we're
very nice other than that.
DAVID KEEGAN: Yeah.
So I don't know if it's around--
and I have had conversations
with friends who are
artists, and they
would be on social
media and they'd
be looking at other
artists on social media
and seeing that they've had this
success, and blah blah blah,
and then they'd go, well,
I'm better than him.
I don't understand why
he's getting that gig.
And they've taken themselves
off social media because--
and not to say that social
media is a terrible thing,
but just to say that
there are impacts with all
of this sharing.
And I suppose what
it comes down to is
like a meaningful
conversation, like you're
having a meaningful
sharing with somebody.
And that's, again, the
purpose of the festival.
It's actually bringing
people out to be at an event
and actually experience it.
Because me talking about a
mental health arts and culture
festival, I'm sure
some of you who
are sitting in the room
who haven't been to it
or been to anything
similar to it
would be like, how
does that even work?
And we were like
that for a few years,
and we were doing
it for a few years
and coming to terms
of what the model is
and what our approach
is and how we affect
change, meaningful change.
And it's all of those things.
And I mean, the
festival is like--
it's a selection box for
mental health discussions.
So a lot of people
don't know the ways
that you can manage
your mental health,
like to balance lifestyle.
And like, obviously,
medication is one approach.
But then your diet has a big
impact on your mental health.
You know, your stress
levels, how social
you are, whether you're getting
enough exercise, those bits
and pieces.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
Time and nature.
DAVID KEEGAN: Yeah, exactly.
Absolutely.
Like, we have a
massive disconnect now
in society from nature, and
when you think about it,
everything's man made around us.
We weren't born-- we're mammals.
We've just lost our
connection to nature.
And just a walk, or
like a bit of exercise,
or addressing some dietary.
Your diet can have a
massive impact on your mood.
And people don't know it.
I know it's anecdotal
to say, well,
of course that's common sense.
Well, it's one thing
saying common sense.
It's another thing--
so well, these
are the things you should
look at to address your diet.
Because, well, what
are you eating?
And again, some of the things
that would happen, say,
in a play, where we would
advertise the general public,
it's not direct or
target marketed to people
who are interested in theater.
It's actually just there
could be like a big name who's
in a theater production and
you might just pop along to it
because a friend brought you.
It's important for us to
contextualize it for someone
where the message isn't
necessarily clear,
or just to provide an
opportunity for questions,
which you're more than
welcome to ask over
the course of this conversation.
But I don't know if that
answers your question.
What's interesting, actually,
is how the priorities
change for us year to year.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: OK.
DAVID KEEGAN: Like, well,
just to give another example,
one of our French
Festival award winners
was an amazing company
called Sunday's Child,
and they did a piece called
"My Name is Saoirse."
And it was around the time
of the abortion referendum.
And her whole piece was
just about the impact on--
so she wrote a piece about
a young girl whose mother
passed away when she was
young, and she had two brothers
and she was being raised
by her father and stuff.
And she had gotten
pregnant unexpectedly
when she was a teenager, but
then lived in a rural town
and then couldn't tell anybody
and couldn't tell her father,
and had to deal
with it on her own,
and not only did she have
to deal with it on her own,
she wasn't ready to have a
child, so wanted to travel away
to have a termination.
So it was about this
experience and the trauma
that she had to go through,
kind of just accepting
that she was in the situation,
having no one to talk
to for fear of it going
to this rural community,
and having to deal with not
only the stigma of getting
pregnant in the
first place, but then
the stigma of having
a termination.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
All on her own.
DAVID KEEGAN: And all on her
own with no access to support.
And just sort of things
like having to get
say a boat as opposed to a
plane for fear of being seen
at an airport by somebody else.
So it made more sense.
So again, that
became like a theme.
And we aren't so arrogant
to just program a festival
without actually
asking our audience
what it is they want to see
in the next festival program.
So we had never programmed
child and family events.
We were kind of broad program
for like a broad demographic,
but never specifically to
other family friendly events.
And then we started to get this
feedback to start doing them.
And that program's
just blown up.
So just to say as well,
we're called First Fortnight
because we start at the
beginning of the new year.
So there's a green
ribbon campaign
run by one of our mental
health partners, See Change,
That happens in May.
And then there's mental health
week which is in October,
World Mental Health Day
is on the 10th of October.
But I suppose our model is
based on my co-founder, JP,
as a psychotherapist
and a social worker.
He would just know from the
beginning of the new year,
or that first quarter, his
caseload would shoot up.
And Christmas is challenging
for a lot of people.
I'm not massively
into Christmas,
and I never have been.
I've never been one
for New Year's either.
But if you've had a
particularly challenging year
and you're facing
into a brand new one,
and you haven't had a
particularly good Christmas
or New Year's, or you've
found it quite stressful,
that first quarter,
that first month,
can be quite challenging.
So that's why we kind
of do it when we do it.
It's to start people off on a
positive mental health note,
explore some of these
teams in the hope
that someone will
come along or someone
will read about us in
an associated article,
and address an issue before
it becomes a serious problem.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: Thank you.
Have we got any questions
from the audience?
I have lots more to
go, but if someone--
great.
You can fire away.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much for coming.
I'm just curious, how do
you pick the pieces that
go into the festival?
Are people coming to you
or are you going to them,
and how has that
changed over the years?
DAVID KEEGAN: Good question.
Yeah, in the beginning we--
so I should also
say that what we do
is only possible because of
the voluntary support we get.
When we started off, again,
we had full time jobs that
paid our rent or our mortgages.
So we did this in
our spare time.
And we've kind of
maintained that model.
We're very grassroots.
And we've kind of grown
to an organization
that-- well, at this stage
we're five employees,
and then we contract employees
or contract staff who
come in and deliver the festival
program in tech and, say,
communications, or
volunteer coordinator.
Well, we'd have 150 people
who will voluntarily
sign up to deliver
the festival program.
Our board is voluntary
and they're 12 people.
And we have an auto
resource team, about seven,
who fundraise on
our behalf, again,
voluntary, and a communications
team of about five,
again, voluntary.
That's the only thing
that makes this possible.
But ultimately, all
of those people,
they are the change makers.
And the sales guys will
help us to program.
In the background, as I
said, we're five staff.
But I mentioned, we run a
center for creative therapy.
So we employ two art therapists
to work with our clients,
and then we've got two
full time staff and then
two other kind of
part time staff.
So some years we do call out
for work, and we'll just,
through our partners,
we'll just look for people
to make submissions
to us, and then
we'd have a panel of
experts who will basically
judge the work based
on our priorities,
and then we'll decide
on the program.
And it comes down to funding, as
well, what funding is available
for the festival program.
And year on year,
the festival just
keeps getting bigger,
and around 20%
between what it cost
in terms of resources,
but in terms of the
actual program itself.
So the ambition
was always that we
would produce a national
mental health festival,
but it's just been very
organic in its development.
It started in Dublin,
and then we kind of
went to the satellite
counties, and then
we kind of identified
Cork as a new hub,
and that festival program
has expanded from one event
into eight.
We're in 24 counties this
year with about 184 events.
With this addition
of the festival
is actually Europe's
Mental Health Festival
that we're presenting,
with participation
from 12 countries, with
two European networks.
So it's kind of a combination.
It's work that we may have
started to develop over
a period of time.
And it's the staple
things that we do,
like the staples being like
we have a flagship music event
at the end of the program.
We do, obviously, our French
Festival award winner.
That goes to whatever
production wins.
And we've got therapy
sessions that happen
in the workmen's every year.
But then the selection
process through the call out--
so it's kind of a
combination of that.
And then we'll have board
members who are interested
or experts in particular
areas, like film or theater,
who will kind of make
recommendations to the board.
So it's kind of a combination
of all those things.
But we're constantly
looking for new work.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
It's a great question.
Do you something
you want to submit?
Maybe.
Excellent.
Any other questions
from the audience?
Yes, at the back of the room.
AUDIENCE: So you
started the conversation
off talking about
stigma of mental health.
And as someone who
has had mental health
issues and problems
the last few years,
I've got a lot of
support from the company
that I've worked
for prior to Google.
And since starting
Google, I've seen
all of the AP, all of
the mental health stuff.
But from a corporate
level, what do you
think a company can do to help
the stigma, particularly around
mental health?
DAVID KEEGAN: Things like this.
I think things like this.
It's a very mature approach
to address and actually kind
of recognizing the impact of
the positive mental health
and well being of staff
on an organization.
And I think the tech
companies, in particular,
have been the leaders in this
approach in my experience.
Because I've done
a couple of these
with a couple of tech
companies, and I've
been really impressed with
the investment in the staff,
and the recognition of the
importance of mental health
and well-being.
I think a lot of
other organizations
could take note and apply some
of the same-- like actually,
mental health week is a good
idea in kind of any company,
or just check-ins with staff.
I don't know if it's-- with some
tech companies provide access
to free mental health care,
or access to therapists,
or like even massages
and stuff like that.
I mean, I never got
that in my profession,
and I don't know that you, when
you were a practicing artist.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: Exactly.
When I was a practicing
artist, there was certainly
none of that kind of support.
But I had a lot of
free time, you know,
for walks on the beach
or things like that.
So I guess I should look
after my own mental health
from my own point of view.
But we are, yeah, we are lucky.
We do have quite a
significant amount of support.
And it is lovely
to have this talk.
And originally, when I was
saying at the beginning,
I wanted David to come in,
I think, back in February,
but I was conscious that he
had just finished the festival,
and then between a
few different things,
I changed the date a few times.
But I think it turned out to be
a lovely timing for the talk,
really, not only for--
well, for the festival,
that's great to support that--
but also because of
everything you've
been saying about the time
of year, the limited sunlight
that we have this time of
year, and just all the effects
that that can have.
So it is great to
continue the conversation.
DAVID KEEGAN: Yeah.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
Any other questions?
Another one at the
front of the room.
Thanks, Marina.
AUDIENCE: So I really liked
what you were talking about,
the events that involve family,
so parents and children.
So you think there's any
gap in terms of teenagers?
I know that my
sister is 16, and I
try and be as open
as possible with her
so that she talks about
it with her friends.
And she said that
they had someone
in talking to them about mental
health, which is something
that I never got in school.
But do you see teenagers
coming to your events,
that kind of age group?
DAVID KEEGAN: Yeah, absolutely.
And we started to
program specifically
for that demographic, who
are massively at risk.
And we're seeing unbelievable
record numbers of anxiety,
particularly amongst
teenagers and younger.
We've partnered, actually,
with SpunOut out this year
to engage with their audiences
on what our messaging is,
but also involving
their audience in work
that we're kind of doing.
There's a massive duty
of care, though, as well,
at the same time.
Because the its
every kind of winter,
we've tried to launch project
where we would work directly
in schools to bring these
conversations to schools,
and actually provide an
opportunity for the youth
to engage with mental
health service providers.
And for kids in schools, it
can be a very toxic place.
So it's work that we
would like to do more of,
but also, we're very conscious
in terms of our duty of care,
that we don't want to just
parachute into a school
and then disappear.
I know you got a
lot of at risk kids
who've been encouraged
to speak openly,
and then there would
be no support for them.
In a lot of cases,
you've got teachers
who are inundated,
under-resourced,
having to be that
front-line, essentially,
therapist, or person
for that kid to talk to.
And they're not
equipped, and they
shouldn't be in that position.
And then you've
got other schools
that would have guidance
counselors who are there,
really, to provide professional
guidance counseling,
and not there from a mental
health and well-being
perspective.
But Jigsaw are doing a
lot of work with schools
and stuff like
that, and SpunOut.
So we're kind of partnering with
them on individual projects.
And as I said, we built our
organization up voluntarily.
We invest heavily in
kind of marketing and PR
communications,
because as I said,
the festival is a medium to
have these conversations.
So it's important
for us to communicate
what's happening
with the festival,
because we're
limited by capacity.
I said we have 184 events
in this festival program.
We're generally able
to 80% occupancy
because we invest so heavily
in the market, communications
in the message.
But our reach is far
greater than the festival
program itself.
So I suppose our
approach is that people
can have the opportunity to
read about what we're doing
and start those kitchen
table conversations.
So it's far more prevalent
to provide the opportunity.
And the festival,
again, it provides
a kind of a safe space where
that conversation's possible.
Because someone's talking
about on stage, and it's like,
Jesus, you know, actually--
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: Maybe it's
OK to start the conversation--
DAVID KEEGAN: Yeah, and
another example of that is--
so we carry out attitudinal
research every year.
And our audience is 70% women.
And we knew that just from,
again, are you male or female?
It's completely anonymous.
But that would hold true with
cultural festivals or the arts,
generally.
There's generally 70%
women, 30% male audiences.
But again, we're about impact.
So we needed to
diversify and engage
with a male kind
of demographic--
I know yours is specific
to kind of younger adults,
but just to give
you an example, I
suppose, we
diversified in sport,
I suppose, to engage
with younger men as well.
We designed an event
called Corinthian,
and have had people, like
for instance, [? Brezzie, ?]
or like--
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: There's
a GAA player, isn't there?
There's a GAA--
DAVID KEEGAN: Don
[? Loke, ?] is it?
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: Yeah.
DAVID KEEGAN:
Yeah, and so, yeah,
we kind of tried to
like-- and again, we're
just responding to what
people want to see, and then
try to match the
ambitions of the festival
with resources in
order to do what we do.
Also, I should say
about our model, what
we do is only possible
through creative collaboration
of partnerships.
It does a lot of logos on the
inside sleeve of that program
from a funding perspective, but
also from a reach perspective.
We have four mental
health partners there.
And without their support and
their help and their advice
year on year, what we
do wouldn't be possible.
We wouldn't be able to
get into 24 counties
and have the impact
that we have.
So Jigsaw for instance,
and SpunOut, do great work.
And we want to do more work with
them in the future to program
and cater for those audiences.
Because again,
there's record numbers
in depression and anxiety
in younger people, and--
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
So Jigsaw and SpunOut.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
I just think it's
such an amazing medium to get
the conversation going on it--
DAVID KEEGAN: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: --and
everything you do.
Thank you so much.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
Another quick question.
We might get a time check.
Can somebody--
are we OK on time?
Before we go to another
audience question,
kind of a bit of a segue
then into the service
provision that you're
moving into and advocacy,
and what does that
change mean for festival?
What does it mean for
you and your workload?
And what should we expect
from you guys next?
DAVID KEEGAN: OK, well,
that's a big question.
So yeah, our advocacy work
has been through the festival
and growing the festival.
So I mean, the presentation
of this European edition
of our festival, that started
in 2015, believe it or not,
when Dublin were in
part of the Dublin 2020
bid, when we were invited to
be part of the Dublin 2020 bid.
And we were listening to all of
the great benefits, city gains,
from winning the award of
capital city of culture.
European city of culture?
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: Yeah.
DAVID KEEGAN: And we kind of
had this collective thought
where like, well,
why couldn't there
be a European mental
health festival?
That would bring not only the
benefits that we were hearing,
but also the social
benefits that I suppose
our festival bring
to mental health
and well-being of the respective
city that it would visit.
And that's how that started.
And then 2016, we were
part of a partnership that
produced Europe's first mental
health festival in Athens
in October 2016.
An outcome of that
was the establishment
of a network for mental health
festivals, a European network
for mental health festivals.
We made a bid to
that network to host
Europe's second mental
health festival in Ireland.
And it was successful, and
that's where we are today.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
That's January?
DAVID KEEGAN:
That's this January.
That's what you'll
see this year.
So we're switching
international little island now
at this stage.
And now, more than ever, with
kind of alt-right movements
gathering momentum
across countries like--
well, a lot of Europe, but
of particular, now probably
Italy and Hungary, and with--
can I use the word
Brexit in this--
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: We
talked about not using it.
DAVID KEEGAN: I know, like, I
didn't know a way around saying
it without saying it--
happening in March,
this is an opportunity
in January with that looming
in March to celebrate
two things that connect us
despite everything else,
and that's our culture and our
mental health and well-being.
So yeah, so just to come
back down, our our intention
is to actually roll out free
mental health care for artists
and artistic communities across
the country by Q3 of next year.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
That's amazing.
DAVID KEEGAN: That's
been a massive--
so we would identify them as--
I mean, they're core to
everything that we do,
and I, personally,
am in awe of artists.
Because you know, they
have a lot of strength
and the courage to get up
on stage in the first place,
but also to open their
heart to subject matter that
is really challenging.
And share it with us
in the hope that it
has impact with audiences.
In collaboration with
several partners,
we kind of talked about this
idea of free mental health
care for that
particular community,
and that's something
that will roll out
by September next year.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
Well, that'll
be an amazing achievement.
DAVID KEEGAN: Yeah.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: Can you
tell us how can our audience,
or any of their friends
and their family,
get involved either next
year or the following year
at this stage maybe?
DAVID KEEGAN: Yeah,
you can find out
everything else about the
festival on our website.
It's just firstfortnight.ie.
So I mean, you
all have-- there's
a festival program there.
All the details are
on our festivals.
As I said, it's
across the country.
So and hopefully there's
something there for everyone.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: What
day does the festival start?
DAVID KEEGAN: January 1.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: January 1?
DAVID KEEGAN: Yeah, and
it's a whole month now.
So it's actually, the
first events on the first
and the last events on the 30th.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
Going to change your name?
DAVID KEEGAN: Well, it always
starts in the first two
weeks of the year.
But we've actually, even though
[INAUDIBLE] never actually been
a [INAUDIBLE]--
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
It'll eventually
be the first quarter.
DAVID KEEGAN: First quarter.
I don't know.
For my own sanity
and mental health,
I think one month
is probably enough.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
Any final questions
from the audience [INAUDIBLE]
conscious of time?
We're all good?
Oh.
There's just one at
the front of the room.
This one more.
AUDIENCE: You kind of hit the
nail on the head when you said,
like, you know, Christmas can
be pretty shit for people.
Do you have any kind
of tips or advice
on like, how we can kind of
look for friends and family
over Christmas who
might be going through--
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
Great closing question.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: --a tough time?
DAVID KEEGAN: It's check-ins.
It's making the time, you know?
A lot of people know when
your friends aren't right
or your family aren't right.
And it is just--
it's having a cup of tea
to making the time to--
and it can be quite challenging.
Because we're running around
buying Christmas presents
like lunatics, and
closing off, trying
to finish off your
loose ends, so you
can walk away without
worrying about that email
that I didn't send.
And it's again, stress
upon stress upon stress,
but it's difficult to
try and make that time,
but it is really important.
And again, I'll give
you another example.
We diversified in sport.
We applied for an award that
we subsequently didn't get.
We got shortlisted for
it, but we didn't actually
get the award.
But a person was involved
with that award scheme was
part of the big multinational.
And he told me about a story
that he'd brought friends
to come to our festival.
The reason he brought
his friend was his friend
was going through a tough time.
And he knew something
was wrong, but he
didn't know how to bring it up.
So he thought, I'll bring
him along to Corinthian
and see if it jars
something with him.
Brought him along to
Corinthian, and on the way home,
they were walking home.
His friend actually
said, you know what?
I'm actually not in a
good place at the moment.
They went for something
to eat and had a coffee
and talked it through,
and he decided
he's actually going to book put
himself in for some therapy.
So that's one way.
But it's kind of checking
in with people, really.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: So
be brave and check in.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's tough.
Thank you, David.
It's been a pleasure
having you today,
and I'm sorry it took me
so long to get you in.
And best of luck in January.
DAVID KEEGAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]